Good evening.
I trust you've had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, but I hope it has been happy.
Namo dasa bhagavato arahato samma sambodasa
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambuddhasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
I've been put onto a discourse
by uh nori and it's uh it involves a woman now you might think why haven't i included women well it's not been my main focus where it's a man or a woman but more the teachings but unfortunately uh women teachers in the discourses are few and far between it's the age we can put it down to the age so let me tell you something about damadina
Dhammadina was an eminent teri, so she was an elder of the bhikkhunis, the nuns, ranked foremost among nuns who possessed the gift of preaching.
She was a wife of Visakha, of Rajagaha, Rajgir.
Remember, that's where King Bimbisara lived.
And when he, having heard the Buddha preach, became an anagami, in other words, having heard the Buddha preach, he reached the third level of liberation,
She left the world with the consent of a husband who sent her to a nunnery in a, oops, just a minute, oops, in a golden palanquin.
There we are, now that's respect for you.
Dwelling in solitude, she suantained at a hatchet
and she later returned to Rajagaha to worship the Buddha and there Visakha asked her questions on the dharma which she answered as easily as one might cut the low stalk with a knife questions and answers are given so that's what we're going to have a look at tonight now here's a little bit of uh
the mythical age.
In the time of Padmumuttara Buddha, so we're talking eons ago, she was a servant and one day saw the Buddha's disciple, Sujata, begging alms and gave him curry.
Her master, seeing this, made her his daughter-in-law.
And later, while on a visit to the Vihara, she saw a nun declared to be a chief of preachers and wished for a similar eminence.
And even before that, in the time of Pusa Buddha, she obtained merit by giving the Buddha's half-brother double the gift prescribed by her husband.
And in the time of Kasaba Buddha, she was born as Sudama, the sixth of seven daughters of Kiki, king of Benares.
For 20,000 years, she lived in celibacy.
There we are.
now let's get to these questions oh my goodness just looking at the light this discourse is called the uh the shorter series of questions and answers and it's a husband actually who's coming who's coming to uh ask questions so she's been given the name of foremost in preaching or teaching by the buddha and this again is in uh
in Rajgir or Rajagaha, present-day Rajgir, which was the seat of Bimbisara, king of Magadha.
So he approaches and says, Lady, personality, what is personality called by the Blessed One?
Now, we've done this, so this is a little test.
I'm going to repeat that again, and I'm going to give you a few seconds to decide what it is, all right?
so personality what is called personality by the blessed one these five aggregates affected by clinging are called personality by the blessed one that is the body
The body, feeling, perception, habits, formations, mental, volitional formations, habits, and consciousness, all of them affected by clinging.
Now, if you got that, you can give yourself a score of two.
If you sort of got close to it, one.
If you didn't get it at all, zero.
So now what he's saying here, of course, person, personality.
Person, personality is, of course, identity.
So it's the aggregates that are affected by clinging.
Clinging is just a way of saying that association of me, of the self.
This is me.
Okay?
i am my body i am my feelings i am what i think i am what i do and i am my consciousness of all this okay so that's identity so then he goes on he says that visaka a former husband was delighted and rejoiced and then he asked a further question lady what is the origin of personality according to the buddha
Okay, three seconds.
What is the origin of personality according to the Buddha?
It is craving which brings renewal of becoming, is accompanied by delight and lust and delights in this and that.
That is craving for sensual pleasures, craving for becoming and craving for non-becoming.
this is called the origin of person personality by the buddha now if you got that give yourself two if you got close to it one and if you didn't zero so here we have craving so this is that tanha that um wrong desire based on a wrong understanding that true happiness can be found in the sensual world
and we have the three cravings, right?
The one is for just pleasure, just the ordinary place of life, however you might describe that.
But then there's this craving also to keep living, to keep becoming, right?
And remember the craving not to become.
So that is also part of our ability to zonk out when we're a bit depressed or we don't want to be around and we just do the duvet dive or just lie out on the couch.
At worst, of course, it's suicide.
So there we have it.
Personality is caused by identity with the five aggregates, this psychophysical organism.
And the cause of that is craving or this wrong desire.
And so now we have another question.
Cessation of personality, cessation of personality.
What is called cessation of personality or personhood by the Blessed One?
Okay, you've got three seconds.
It is the remainderless fading away and ceasing, the giving up, relinquishing, letting go and rejecting of that same craving.
This is called the cessation of personality or personhood.
if you got that give yourself two and if you got close to it one if you didn't get it at all zero one hard so what we're looking at of course the four noble truths yeah okay this this is now this is an easy one this is an easy one
Lady, the way leading to the cessation of personality, the cessation of personhood.
So this is the four noble truths based upon the idea of a self.
What is that called?
What is called the way leading to the cessation of personality?
Now, I've given it away, so you must get that one right.
I don't want anybody to go with complete zero.
What is the way leading to the cessation of personality?
It is just this noble eightfold path.
Right view, right intention, right speech, right action, right livelihood, right effort, right mindfulness, and right concentration.
So if you've got that, give yourself two.
If you've sort of got it, one.
But I don't think anybody's not got it.
I'd be very surprised, dreadful.
Now, here's the tricky one.
okay this is when it gets a wee bit careful now it gets a bit tricky okay so now is that clinging so this is the self the um identity the same as the five aggregates affected by clinging or is the clinging something apart from the five aggregates affected by clinging is it the same or is it something separate
What do you think?
This is Damodina's answer.
That clinging is neither the same as the five aggregates affected by clinging, nor is clinging something apart from the five aggregates of clinging.
It is the desire and lust in regard of the five aggregates affected by clinging that is the clinging here.
or there so see if we can uh deconstruct that the clinging is neither the same right so in what way is it the same right it's the same because of that identity one when we talk about identity we mean a loss of objectivity it's it's like this is what i am at its most uh obvious um
way would be when we get completely lost in an emotion when you know we are the anger or we are the joy or the excitement that's that's what we mean by identity so in that sense it's the same
But it is apart because it cannot arise without the five aggregates.
In other words, there's no clinging, there's no self unless there are five aggregates.
So therefore, and of course it is a consequence of this desire, this deluded desire to seek happiness in the sensual world.
So it is, although it is the same, it is something else because it doesn't arise if there's no clinging, right?
If there's no wrong understanding through desire, the self doesn't, this clinging self doesn't arise.
So that was a bit tricky, wasn't it?
So I didn't put that to you as a, there's no marks for that one, unless you actually knew it.
So you can add up your score.
Now you should have six or four or at least two.
So you can pat yourself on the back.
Okay, now the next bit gets even more complicated and I'm just wondering whether we can go for it.
well okay let's try so now how does personality view come to be personality view come to be right the the now there's a difference between the sense of self and the view of self the view of self is the wrong understanding the sense of self is that feeling we have of being me okay
Here Visakha, an untaught ordinary person who has no regard for the noble ones and is unskilled and undisciplined in their dharma, who has no regard for true men, people, and is unskilled and undisciplined in their dharma, regards material form as self, or self as possessed of material form.
material form as in self or self as in material form it's a killer isn't it so is they regards the body as the self or the self possessing the body or the body is in the self or the self is in the body okay now then
There's a piece I've taken out from Annalio's book.
I think it's in his How to Be with Death and Dying or something.
This book about death and dying is excellent, by the way.
And he points this out.
The five aggregates of clinging represent different components of what one tends to cling to.
So the physical body would be where I am.
feeling would be how i am perception would be what i am uh the uh habits and everything is why i am and consciousness whereby i am so that's just an aside okay so let's get back to this body and business so if we do it with a body
we can do it with the other four, right?
And according to the note, these are the 20 kinds of personality view.
So the first one is the body and the self are one.
Okay, so the commentary says, it's like the flame of a burning oil lamp is identical with its color.
So the body and the self are considered by the person as one of the same thing.
The self possesses the body, right?
The next one was, hold on, the next one was, I'm going to keep flashing back and forward here.
The next one was the self as regards, form as self, the self as possessed of.
In other words, it possesses the body.
So that's one of possession.
Oh, like when we say I have a bad knee.
and this is um as a tree possesses a shadow so the self and the body are not one but the body but the self does own it has a relationship of ownership and then the next one was gonna flip back again excuse me uh
material form as in the self the material form is in the self so the image it gives as a scent is in the flower as a scent is in the flower so here the body the body um and the self are the same but the self is greater
right is greater the body is in the self but the self is greater than the body so it's there's still that um there's still that identity but the person feels that the self is bigger than the body right is more than the body okay and the last one is that the self is part of the body isn't it yeah the self is in the material body or in matter
so this the image there is of a jewel in a casket of a jewel in a casket so the self is simply a part of the body right
And if you think of the body, it does have its own automatic, autonomic ways of doing things, like the creation of blood and all that.
So the self is, as it were, encased in the body.
It's a different form of identity.
So the four identities are, I am the same as, a pure identity, one of possession,
separate separate but the one is greater than the other the body is greater than the self or the self is greater than the body okay it's all very confusing don't you think
but this is the self as opposed as to the body.
You can do the same with feeling, you can do the same with perceptions, and you can do the same with the habits, yeah?
And you can do the same with consciousness.
And it all adds up to six, what is it?
Five, four, 12, what does he say?
I get confused.
20, 20 different kinds of selves.
so in what way does this help us you know that's the question isn't it i mean you know well uh it's a case of using it as a contemplation and in your sitting uh just ask yourself you know what's this sense of self i have what's its relationship to the body what's its relationship to feeling you see
Every time we're reacting, there's some sense of ownership, some sense of wanting it or not wanting it.
So it's a case of using these reflections, these understandings to actually view our relationship to the body, to our feelings, to the way we think, to all our habits and to consciousness itself.
So I think it might be worth going over that sometime or other.
So I can only hope these words have truly not been confusing and that it will assist you in your journey to final liberation, which will come hopefully sooner rather than later.
So we can begin our practices.